Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera a tutti.
Sono Soufi Nawal,
sono un'attivista per i diritti umani,
tempo fa mi facevo chiamare
"giornalista freelance".
Semplicemente una ragazza,
un essere umano, come tutti voi.
Quello che ho cercato di fare, negli anni,
è cercare di andare a trovare problemi,
e cercare di risolverli in qualche modo:
dalla persona che dorme per strada,
al tossicodipendente,
alle persone che arrivano
con le imbarcazioni in Sicilia.
Vivo a Catania, sono laureanda
in Scienze Politiche
e lavoro in Tribunale
come mediatrice culturale.
Bene, cosa vi devo raccontare
in questi 15 minuti?
Vi racconto quello che batte qui dentro.
Non è possibile studiare nei libri --
possono essere libri di storia,
possono essere altri libri --
non è possibile sapere che un miliardo
della popolazione mondiale è analfabeta,
non è possibile pensare
che un miliardo della popolazione mondiale
non ha accesso all'acqua pulita,
cioè quell'acqua che semplicemente noi,
la mattina, apriamo,
ci facciamo una doccia
che magari dura un'ora e mezzo
o semplicemente quell'acqua che apriamo
per lavare una strada;
non è possibile pensare
che due miliardi
della popolazione mondiale
non hanno l'accesso ai servizi sanitari,
a delle strutture che possano
in qualche modo attenuare.
Nel solo 2005,
più di tre milioni di persone
sono morte per Aids.
Vorrei ricordare a tutti voi
che solo tre giorni,
tre giorni di spese militari nel mondo
equivalgono alle spese di un anno
per la lotta all'Aids.
Allora un fondo di ipocrisia c'è.
Questi sono dati che non servono a nulla:
quello che serve
è realmente fare qualcosa.
Cosa si può fare?
All'età di 14 anni ho iniziato a Catania,
ho iniziato ad accogliere le persone
che arrivano con le imbarcazioni.
Tutti coloro che arrivano in Sicilia
passano dalle stazioni.
Le strade sono di chi ama,
le stazioni di chi ama.
Scendete semplicemente nelle stazioni,
toccate le persone che continuano
i viaggi, i loro viaggi,
il secondo viaggio della speranza,
verso il nord Europa,
perché l'Italia rimane
un paese di passaggio.
Toccare queste persone,
guardarle negli occhi,
ti rende molto più responsabile,
ti rende semplicemente
un essere umano molto più responsabile.
Io quando esco di casa la mattina
riesco a vedere le mie mani rosse,
semplicemente perché il sangue
al di là del Mar Mediterraneo
mi appartiene, appartiene a tutti noi,
cioè vedere queste mani rosse la mattina,
e rivederle così la sera
è un obiettivo di tutti i giorni.
Io ho iniziato con una mensa,
ho preso una stanza da una Caritas
e inizialmente ho detto
che dovevo semplicemente cucinare.
Con il tempo ho iniziato
a insegnare l'italiano,
ho iniziato a prendere i numeri
di tutti gli avvocati eccetera,
ho iniziato in qualche modo -
e io non amo l'assistenzialismo,
ho sempre cercato in qualche modo
di dare degli strumenti
alle persone che arrivano qui in Italia,
o altrove, anche su Internet -
cercare, in qualche modo,
di tradurre delle informazioni,
rendere le persone partecipi
del loro futuro, semplicemente.
In questa stanza sono riuscita,
insieme a cinque ragazzi,
a cucinare circa per 400 persone,
mentre a Catania non c'era un pranzo,
c'era solamente una sorta di cena
alle cinque e mezzo e alle sette di sera.
E credo che ogni essere umano,
prima di tutta la filosofia
che si può fare -
tutto quello che noi possiamo dire,
credo che l'essere umano prima
deve avere questa piena,
per poi poter ragionare,
per poi poter studiare,
per poi poter fare politica,
e fare tutto quello
che tutti noi facciamo.
Le foto che vedete dietro che scorrono
sono l'accoglienza
in questi ultimi due anni:
sono l'"emergenza siriana" e non solo,
persone che mi hanno conosciuto
dentro la stazione di Catania.
Il primo gruppo erano 50 persone.
Con il tempo hanno preso
il mio numero di telefono
e hanno iniziato a scrivere
il mio numero di telefono su Facebook.
La "Primavera araba"
si è svolta su Facebook,
e il mio numero di telefono -
stranamente, quasi tutte le persone
che decidono di mettere piede
su un'imbarcazione,
hanno il mio numero di telefono.
Da qui il mio lavoro
si è trasformato in qualcosa di diverso,
in qualcosa di molto più faticoso,
ma molto più bello.
Il fatto che una persona ti chiami
da un'imbarcazione
e ti dice: chiama la guardia costiera,
dì loro che siamo 300 persone
uscite da Alessandria,
in navigazione da 10 giorni,
l'imbarcazione è di legno,
c'è stato un trasbordo in mare,
i bambini piangono,
una donna sta per partorire,
le onde sono alte, sta piovendo,
Comunica con la guardia costiera.
Chiami la guardia costiera,
e la guardia costiera ti risponde.
I primi mesi, quando non mi conoscevano,
dopo tre chiamate la guardia costiera
mi ha richiamata dicendomi: "Soufi Nawal?"
Mi hanno dato anche l'indirizzo
di casa mia, giusto per ricordarmelo,
"Lei è stato denunciata
per favoreggiamento
all'immigrazione clandestina".
Mi ricordo che quella serata
andai al primo posto di polizia,
incontrai la Digos
e feci questo: "Arrestatemi".
Sono stata denunciata verbalmente
della guardia costiera
e dal comando generale di Roma.
Lo stesso comando generale di Roma
ha conosciuto questa pazza, questa folle
e adesso il comando generale di Roma
a qualsiasi orario,
tre - quattro del mattino,
chiama per mettermi in chiamate di gruppo
con delle imbarcazioni in difficoltà.
Cosa significa essere
in una chiamata di gruppo
con un'imbarcazione in difficoltà?
Non significa solo tradurre:
anche perché, se fosse solo tradurre,
io la domanda che mi faccio è:
Vivo in Italia da 26 anni,
e non ho mai capito perché
il comando generale di Roma
non abbia un interprete.
Io potrei anche fare da interprete
al comando generale, 24 ore su 24,
senza uno stipendio.
La domanda fondamentale è:
perché non avere un interprete arabo?
140.000 persone
che sono arrivate in Italia,
in questo ultimo anno, dalle imbarcazioni
hanno parlato in arabo:
quando hanno parlato in inglese,
le informazioni che hanno dato
erano basilari.
A volte, il problema fondamentale
non è solo la lingua;
è anche cercare, in qualche modo,
di gestire le persone che stanno a bordo,
cioè gridare, urlare e dire:
"Basta, non mi dare più informazioni
che non hanno un senso,
ad esempio che le donne gridano
e i bambini piangono.
Grazie tante, sei in mare!"
Urlare e dire: Coordinate,
coordinate, coordinate.
La risposta dall'altra parte --
è successo ora,
mentre ero nella stanza nove,
un'imbarcazione ha chiamato adesso,
un'imbarcazione che è uscita dalla Libia,
continuavano a dirmi:
"Non sappiamo prendere le coordinate,
non sappiamo usare il Gps,
perché non ce l'abbiamo,
non sappiamo usare il Gps
che è dentro il telefono Thuraya".
Semplicemente gli ho spiegato
come prendere le coordinate,
me le ha comunicate
e ho chiamato la guardia costiera.
Quello che facciamo, quello che faccio,
insieme ad una ragazza di nome Agata,
dentro la stazione di Catania,
tutte le foto che vedete,
diciamo questo è un giardinetto
vicino alla stazione di Catania.
Prima cosa: fare dei biglietti,
biglietti di treno,
sconto comitiva 68 euro.
Tutti partono felicemente verso Milano.
Da Milano cominciano
il secondo viaggio della speranza
verso il nord Europa,
sfidando il Protocollo di Dublino.
68 euro: vi dico il prezzo
perché dovrei anche parlarvi
dello "scafismo di terra".
Sconfiggere lo scafismo di terra
non lo si sconfigge con gli arresti
e non è mai stato sconfitto
con gli arresti.
A Catania sono riuscita
a bloccare lo scafismo di terra.
e non me ne vanto,
perché tutto quello che faccio
non l'ho mai fatto
per dire che l'ho fatto.
Semplicemente, l'ho fatto
per sentirmi essere umano,
semplicemente tornare a casa
e avere una coscienza pulita,
riuscire a dormire e mangiare
quel poco che ogni giorno
riesco a mangiare
e sentire che realmente me lo merito.
Scafismo di terra:
persone ferme davanti alla stazione,
davanti ai centri di prima accoglienza.
Persone che ti dicono:
"Sali, sali, sali in macchina,
ti portiamo noi a Milano,
a 500 euro, 400 euro.
Non andare in stazione,
perché c'è la polizia,
perché ti identifica con le impronte
e non puoi continuare a viaggiare
verso il nord Europa
per il Protocolo di Dublino".
Bene: tutto questo è sconfitto.
Quello che vedete,
le fotografie dentro la stazione --
ogni giorno partenze di 200-300 persone.
Prima cosa, facciamo i biglietti;
seconda cosa: le schede.
Le schede telefoniche
sono qualcosa di piccolo,
ma di importantissimo
per chi ha fatto una traversata
di dieci, sette, due giorni,
senza che la propria famiglia -
Tanti ragazzi sono partiti
senza dire ai propri familiari
che erano in viaggio.
Un ragazzo è arrivato a Catania dicendomi:
"Dammi il tuo telefono,
voglio chiamare mia madre.
Mia madre sa che sono in Libia".
E io gli ho chiesto:
"Ma non è possibile, sei partito
senza dire alla tua famiglia
che eri in mare?"
Mi ha risposto e mi ha detto:
"Mi vergogno delle lacrime di mia madre.
Le voglio sentire adesso,
ma devono essere lacrime di gioia".
La terza cosa che facciamo:
andare nelle banche, ma anche di Catania,
semplicemente per fare a queste persone
cambio da dollari ad euro,
semplicemente indicando a queste persone
quello che bisogna fare,
senza ricorrere a persone che,
per strada magari,
possono dar loro dei soldi falsi.
Un'altra cosa importantissima:
dopo che si fanno tutti i bigletti,
dopo che si cerca, in qualche modo,
di scherzare, di ridere,
arriva il momento importante
che è quello delle informazioni.
Raccolgo tutte le persone
dentro la stazione di Catania,
metto un megafono qui,
giro il megafono dietro
e il microfono avanti,
perché fa sempre
una sorta di interferenza.
Quelli che stanno dietro soffrono,
perché sentono questa voce;
e quelli che stanno avanti
cercano in qualche modo di -
Oddio, questa ci sta
per dare informazioni,
ci sta per dire
che noi non possiamo continuare
il nostro viaggio verso il nord Europa,
ci sta per parlare
del Protocollo di Dublino.
Bene, cerco in qualche modo
di dar loro tutte le informazioni
e tra queste informazioni anche:
"Guardate che partite col treno
Villa San Giovanni-Milano",
da Villa S.G. fino a Napoli state attenti,
chiudetevi e prendete le cinture,
chiudete la porta.
Non per qualche cosa,
ma siccome sono qua da 26 anni
so che qualcuno potrebbe aprire la porta
e so che potrebbero scomparire
i soldi che avete".
Dopo di che cerco, in qualche modo,
di dare tutte le informazioni
che possono servire a queste persone.
Che siano informazioni legali,
o che siano informazioni,
in qualche modo, anche banali.
Questa foto, questa è una
delle foto che più amo.
Durante questi due anni
son successe tantissime cose,
dentro la stazione di Catania.
I due ragazzi che vedete
con questo melone spezzato in due
e con i numeri 25.
Ve la racconto:
stavamo facendo dei biglietti,
vedo che la sua data di nascita
è il primo agosto.
Io ho una filosofia del mare.
La filosofia del mare è la seguente:
Le persone che mettono piede
su un'imbarcazione,
quando scendono a terra,
sono nati per la seconda volta.
È una nuova nascita,
semplicemente perché devi ricominciare,
devi imparare una lingua,
e ti serve qualcuno che ti spieghi
dove si trova il panificio più vicino,
ti serve qualcuno che ti spieghi
che dentro la stazione,
per poter andare in bagno,
devi spendere un euro,
magari hai mangiato anche un panino
che costava 50 centesimi,
ma questo non [cambia nulla]:
devi spendere un euro.
Qui, questo ragazzo faceva il compleanno,
ed era il primo agosto.
Mi ricordo che quella giornata,
durante l'accoglienza
di circa 300 persone,
mi arrivarono in quella giornata
sette S.O.S. in questo telefono.
Sette S.O.S. che io registro sempre,
perché persone che mi hanno chiamata
non sono mai arrivate.
Tante di quelle persone
che hanno lanciato un S.O.S.
non sono mai arrivate.
Persone a cui non ho mai fatto
un biglietto del treno,
persone che non hanno
mai preso il mio telefono,
persone che non mi hanno
mai detto: "Dov'è il bagno?",
persone che non mi hanno mai chiesto
cos'è il Protocollo di Dublino,
o che cos'è la Bossi-Fini.
[Con] questo ragazzo cos'abbiamo fatto?
Semplicemente, ci siamo messi d'accordo
insieme a ragazzi
che hanno viaggiato con lui
e hanno fatto la traversata con lui,
e ho detto: bene,
ma che sorpresa possiamo fargli
prima della partenza?
Vabbè, una torta costa 20 euro,
io in tasca ho 5 euro, non si può.
Va bene, ok decidiamo: un melone.
Non se lo dimenticherà mai,
perché una torta è molto semplice,
il melone no.
Due euro, due candele, finito il discorso.
Complice il mio amico,
abbiamo cominciato questo:
"Tanti auguri a te" in tre lingue:
arabo, inglese e italiano.
In italiano ero la sola,
mi guardavano come una pazza.
Ci sono piccole cose,
anche quando non hai fondi,
anche quando non ti arrivano
mille euro al giorno,
anche quando ti arrivano
mille euro all'anno,
ci sono piccole cose che possono cambiare
la vita, lo sguardo,
le sensazioni delle persone.
Anche questo può cambiare tanto:
cioè tu stai facendo
accoglienza, sei una spugna:
io mi sento una spugna
quando faccio accoglienza,
perché mentre fai il biglietto,
mentre cammini con una persona
verso il bagno,
mentre vai verso l'ufficio
della Western Union,
mentre vai verso la banca sei una spugna.
Una spugna in che senso?
Cosa fa una spugna?
C'è dell'acqua a terra,
metti questa spugna,
questa spugna assorbe.
Assorbi l'uomo che ti dice:
"Hanno sgozzato i miei tre bambini,
davanti ai miei occhi;
hanno giustiziato mio figlio;
hanno ucciso mia madre;
hanno stuprato mia sorella".
Qui ti rendi conto
che quei discorsi della serie:
"O mio Dio, ma qui c'è la crisi economica,
non è che li possiamo prendere tutti"
La risposta ovvia è:
l'86% delle persone che sono uscite,
o almeno che hanno lasciato
la Siria, in questi anni,
sono nei paesi limitrofi,
cioè Libano, Giordania, Turchia.
Cosa ha preso l'Italia,
l'Europa in generale?
Quanti ne ha presi, quanti ne ha accolti?
Bene, qualcuno è rimasto in fondo al mare:
Per la tanta speranza,
non per disperazione.
Quando metti i piedi in un'imbarcazione,
non lo fai mai perché sei disperato.
Lo fai perché la speranza,
dentro il tuo cuore, è talmente grande
che ti spinge a fare
uno dei passi più pericolosi [possibili].
È molto più pericoloso
salire a bordo di un'imbarcazione,
prendere questa decisione,
e non, ad esempio, entrare dentro Homs,
una città assediata da circa due anni.
Bene, un bambino ti guarda,
finiamo i bigletti,
tu magari non hai i soldi per comprare
50 chili di cioccolata per tutti i bambini
e fai semplicemente questo gesto,
ora se ho il fiato -
Lui ti guarda, lo chiudi,
continua a guardarti,
ti rendi conto che forse non ha più visto
un palloncino da tre anni.
Glielo dai, ti guarda
e ti ringrazia in un modo particolare,
un modo diverso
da come ringraziano tutti gli adulti.
Gli adulti ringraziano [così]:
Grazie, grazie, grazie,
T'abbiamo chiamato dal mare, grazie.
Invece, i bambini ringraziano
in un modo particolare,
i bambini si appendono qua,
non abbracciano,
i bambini si appendono qua.
Quando un bambino si appende qui,
tutta la stanchezza
che ti sei portato avanti,
per un anno, per due anni qui,
che te la senti la sera
quando vai a dormire,
scappa via, va via.
Questo tipo di accoglienza
ha dei pro e dei contro,
ovviamente lavori tra favoreggiamento
all'immigrazione clandestina -
eh sì, la Bossi-Fini,
oddio, reato di immigrazione clandestina -
non ci capisci più niente.
Io mi sono sempre fatta una domanda:
tanta gente mi ha incontrata
nella stazione di Catania
e mi ha detto:
Ma veramente tutto quello
che tu fai è legale?
La mia risposta è stata, sempre:
"Perché abbiamo arrestato Eichmann?
Perché abbiamo preso tanti generali
dopo la caduta del nazismo?
Perché?"
Era tutto legale.
Era tutto legale!
L'umanità, e la legalità.
Certe persone, nella storia,
riescono a prendere degli ordini
e portare avanti questi ordini.
Io credo che non esiste ordine più grande
di quello che ti da il cuore.
Cosa potete fare tutti voi,
tu, tu, lei, cosa?
Milano, 36 minuti da qui.
Dalla stazione di Milano
se noi chiedessimo a tutti i rifugiati
che passano da questa stazione
di scrivere un foglio,
e di raccontare in questo foglio
la propria storia,
io credo che tutti noi
smetteremmo di comprare
delle cose che non hanno alcun senso,
come il prossimo iPhone6.
E tante persone non hanno bisogno
né di cibo, né di niente:
hanno semplicemente bisogno
di un abbraccio, di una carezza.
Un bambino che è il 233,
mi ricorda tanto certe epoche
che ho studiato nella Storia.
A proposito: questo numero
è molto più dignitoso
rispetto a un altro numero.
Tante volte i rifugiati mi spuntano,
arrivano in stazione con 233.
Io, quando vedo questo, [dico]:
fratello, per favore, copriti.
Copriti perché non riesco a continuare
la giornata di accoglienza.
Vorrei lanciare una cosa,
che è una provocazione:
io ho notato che il pane
costa più dei farmaci,
e questo l'ho scoperto
quando dovevo scendere in Siria.
C'era un ospedale da campo che mi chiedeva
paracetamolo per i bambini.
Mi sono resa conto che cento pillole
di paracetamolo costavano tre euro.
Siccome scadevano dopo sette mesi,
me le hanno vendute a un euro.
No, io non ci ho creduto.
Cento pillole di paracetamolo, un euro.
Ed è impensabile
che un bambino possa morire
perché ha una febbre alta.
Semplicemente impensabile.
Questo tipo di accoglienza
ha un'altra parte che è molto difficile,
ed è la parte dei naufragi.
Quando c'è un naufragio, smetti di vivere.
Smetti di vivere
nel vero senso della parola.
Io ho smesso di vivere il 2 agosto,
ho smesso di vivere il 24 agosto,
ho smesso di vivere il 6 settembre,
ho smesso di vivere l'11/10 del 2013,
il 03/10 del 2013.
I morti: i morti -
i familiari non credono mai
che i loro figli siano morti.
Non esiste, ad ora, fino a questo momento,
né in Croce Rossa Italiana, né altro,
una lista delle persone morte,
o dei cadaveri,
quindi i familiari chiamano gli attivisti
per avere informazioni.
Grazie a tutti.
(Applausi)